yeah no thank you so much David
um yeah I'm also really sorry not to be
able to be there in person
um
but I'm very thankful that you're able
to accommodate a virtual um talk with
very little preparation so
um thank you David and thank you Isabel
for uh trading over
um so
I'm Franz Jensen I'm a biologist here at
office University in Denmark
um
and I can pretty much guarantee that at
least I'll take the technical side of
this down at least a notch so
um what I'll be talking about today is
oops
um individual discrimination of modern
stuff and signature whistles using a
deep learning framework
and we're going to start by giving you a
little bit of an overview of berminus
dolphins
um and especially their social and
cognitive complexity
um then I'll go through a little bit of
what we know about acoustic
communication environmental stuffins
they've been studying for quite a long
time
um they're kind of the white lab red of
Dell Finance so
um please consider that all a very brief
overview and not a thorough review at
all
um then I'll go through why um I think
we want or we're moving towards
increasing acoustic monitoring and
building acoustic monitoring efforts
through uh the use of Automotive stuff
and signature whistles I'll go through a
little bit about our field site where we
are dual field research and develop
these methods
um and then I'll go through some of the
database that um that we've developed
and also a couple of their machine
learning tools that we've been working
on
so buttonless dolphins live in these um
large fluid fission fusion societies
um they come together
um stay together for a few hours split
apart again
um and they maintain many long-term
social bonds in these fish infusion
societies
in um Sarasota where we've been studying
um Wellness dolphins and where the
longest running uh field study of
bottomless Dolphins uh happens
um bottomless Dolphins tend to form
either male alliances these are
alliances are formed
um by males in their teens as they
associate and find partners that they
prefer to hang out with
and then also or the other stable type
of unit in this social network are
bottlenose dolphin mom cough Pairs and
to some lesser degree
female groups with other
um
often related individuals
um if we move across uh the globe over
to shock Bay where another of the
long-running
um field studies of one of those
Dolphins happen this one focusing on
testy doncus or a different species here
bonus Dolphins form much more
sophisticated or much more complex
alliances of males that compete against
one another or between one another facts
as two females and for meeting
opportunities the alliances here can
range across three different levels
um they they have the basic pairs or
trios of
um first order alliances but those are
very fluid instead it's the second order
alliances that are much more permanent
so you see here a social network with
um yellows being one second order lines
Blues being a second different second
order Alliance and reds being a third
second order Alliance and those are the
much more our fundamental social unit
for males in um in shock Bay and they
also associate sometimes in this um
super Alliance where where they can
Aggregate and compete for other
secondary against other secondary
alliances permitting opportunities
so these complex social lives also
accompanied by a very high cognitive
complexity they'll Finance have one of
their highest brain to body mass ratios
in um among citations rivaling that of
non-human primates they have a large
cerebellum size they have a high
encephalization portion so many of these
anatomical features uh point to them
being quite uh cognitively sophisticated
they also evolved um very Exquisite
social learning and also problem solving
skills there's been a lot of studies
done on this over the many many decades
especially by Louis Herman and Adam Peck
um
and so they're they're really good at
solving problems and solving tasks so
this picture here is from a task that
they're that pairs of dolphins were
trained to solve in captivity
um back in 2016.
given the prevalence of these male
alliances
um of course it's not uh surprising that
there is also extensive cooperation in
bottomless Dolphins they cooperate
um among males
um for herding uh females and acts
having access to mating opportunities
there's extensive evidence of corporates
foraging
um they can cooperatively solve
different uh tasks that you can train
them to
um so there's a lot of sophisticated
um
um problem solving here and oftentimes
in requiring interactions between
individuals and here in the right here I
show a figure from
um Stephanie King's paper in 21 where
they were a training bottomless Dolphins
to solve a Cooperative task in uh under
control conditions and the animals would
coordinate using acoustic signals so in
the bottom here you see a spectrogram
um it's labeled
um you have time on the x-axis and
um frequency on the y-axis and it's
color-coded according to intensity so
what you see under right above Race is a
whistle going down right over Delta is a
whistle going up and down and then right
over Rhys again there's another
frequency modulated whistle so they're
coordinating to uh acoustically to solve
these um these tasks
and beyond that there's a lot of
evidence for of course the complex Error
Alliance formation and increasingly also
evidence from the field with playback
studies that these animals have as a
concept of who their Partners is so here
in the right we have a figure from
Stephanie King in Shark Bay during
playback experiments with bottomless
dolphin or signage whistles testing
whether or not they can differentiate
between second order and third order
Alliance mates and showing that they
indeed do respond much more to their
primary the secondary
um second order Alliance rather than
third order Alliance mates
so acoustically there's a lot of
variation in bottomless Dolphins they
use clicks and uh foraging buses in
scene here in the very tub to forage to
echolocate or throughout the environment
and to find and catch prey items but
they also have a wide range of um
communication signals so here I in the
bottom of my show some jaw clubs a
couple of burst pulses rasps and some
low frequency and airplane sounds and
I'm just gonna see if I can play a
sequence so this is a sound sequence
from an aggressive interaction between a
couple of mom cough or one mom cough
pair and a couple of males one male
lines that's interacting with these are
this mom craft here
foreign
signals or sometimes also called quacks
that the males are using extensively
during these social interactions there's
also a couple of these jaw claps in the
start they're very loud
um
then there's a couple of burst poses
right in the middle of the sequence
um but these in social interactions can
be quite complex and consist of a lot of
these different social uh signals that
they're using and we still have a lot to
do in order to understand
um the concepts and the function of many
of these signals although we have
hypotheses for for most of them
especially jaw clouds the low frequency
in urban sounds
Beyond these uh post and low frequency
signals of course there's also a wide
range of frequency modulated whistles so
here's an example of
um a signature whistle from one one
individual
and I'm good
so it goes up and down in frequency and
then up and down in frequency again so
these are two Loops of the same
signature whistle
oh
so the signature the whistle repertoire
of buttonhouse dolphins is quite um
extensive as well we know a lot about
signature whistles and I'm gonna get to
that in uh one slide we know much less
about
non-signature whistles even though
around 40 to 50 percent of signature of
whistles produced by wild unrestrained
animals or non-signature whistles
um so here's a slide from one of my
students that was looking at
non-signature Whistle repertoires by
Adelaide males showing that they do have
a subset of their non-signature whistle
repertoires that they share and also
that they are exchange during social
interactions especially at the start of
social interactions with other con
specifics
um but there's a lot more to do with
non-signature whistles it's it's a very
poorly um study field
what we do know a little bit about is um
second choice and we've known about
sticking to whistles since uh the
Caldwell's uh seminal study in 1965
where they showed that each individual
dolphin produces a distinct what they
call Signature whistle
um and that was the predominant whistle
when the animals were in isolation
isolated from other specifics
um so here you have a couple of examples
of the time frequency Contour the
fundamental frequency Contour of five
different uh signature whistles from
their study
these signature whistles develop early
in life they developed through uh vocal
production learning
um and that they tend to be stable for
throughout the lifetime of the the
individuals
we also know that and uh Dolphins can
discriminate the con specific signature
whistles they can recognize familiar uh
con specific signature whistles and they
recognize individuals based on the
pattern of the time frequency Contour so
you can remove all the other information
but the time frequency Contour shown
here in the bottom right
and the animals will still correctly
recognize familiar versus unfamiliar
specifics
so these signature whistles are
essential for Dolphin societies
they're used for maintaining or even
re-establishing cohesion when animals
are temporarily separated but they're
also used when groups meet up at Sea to
exchange identity information and
presumably to to greet each other
um
after separations
recognition of con specifics happen over
decades
um there's been
data showing that even animals in
captivity that have been separated from
specifics because of animals being moved
from one facility to another recognize
those signature whistles over more than
a decade of absence
and that allows for this formation of
these very complicated differentiated
social relationships the formation of
stable social bonds for example as we
see in the male alliances in complex
Cooperative relationships
we also know that Dolphins differentiate
specifically The Cooperative Partners
throughout the through signature
whistles and then signature whistle
exchanges help build or even maintain
those are bonds at a distance
and finally there's evidence of
referential signaling bottomless
Dolphins will occasionally copy each
other's signature whistles and there's
oftentimes subtle modifications so you
can differentiate a copy from an
original
um and they can do that to attract that
individual's attention so that's been
shown uh in some male or male Pairs and
also from Mom cough pairs
so the fact that these signature
whistles are so fundamental to button
those dolphin societies means there's a
large potential for doing acoustic
monitoring through uh listening for
detecting and ultimately classifying
individuals by their signature whistles
so Emma Longden did a seminal study back
in 2020 using macro capture analyzes
based on bottomless stuff and signature
whistles to get a robust population as
the abundance estimate for their
publishing that she was looking at in
valve base but Bay Namibia where she
found an acoustic estimate of 2054 to 68
individuals and that corresponded very
well with their visual estimate of 54 to
76 individuals in this area
it was based on a very small population
and much of the work was done by hand
individually comparing uh whistle
Contours and identifying
um Contours that were the same
so there's a lot of
um opportunity here in indeed a need for
developing automated maybe if more
efficient signal processing pipelines
um that can allow us to go from raw
acoustic recordings over to
um an overview of the different
signature whistles and ultimately to
monitor populations based on their
signature whistles and for subsequent
robust field validation with more
natural bigger populations
um
so the field side where we operate is
based out of Sarasota in Florida it's
the longest running
um field study of probably citations
um definitely of Dell Finance it's been
running for more than 50 years by now
and um this in this area Randy Wells and
his team organize regular both or
continuous year-round service of the
local bottom stuff in publishing is
around 160 to 117 individuals big
depending on uh the year
and then they do intermittent uh regular
Health assessments where they
um routinely capture animals uh
implement or conduct a physiological uh
morphological and uh hormonal or health
assessment of these animals and then
release the animals back into the wild
so this allows for a lot of detailed
work to be done with these animals both
during the captures and afterwards all
the individuals down here that have been
captures all so free stranded and that
greatly facilitates following these
animals year over year and throughout
their lifetime
I'm part of a an aggregation of
um some some four other pis looking at
Acoustic communication of these animals
including
um
Peters Hayek and Vincent Yannick and we
look at communication through our
through a lot of different methods first
of all throughout the last 35 years
during these captures or animals that
have been captured have been implemented
with suction cup hydrophones and allows
us to collect whistles from each
captured individual and to relate those
whistles specifically to known
individual identified animals
we Implement playback experience both
during the captures and with wild
animals to empirically test our
hypotheses for communication and
cognition and behavior of these animals
we implement or instrument animals with
d tags sound and movement recording tags
right at the end of the captures and
those tags then keep recording both the
sounds and the movement of the animals
throughout the next 6 12 18 up to 24
hours after their health assessment is
completed
and finally we you do acoustic
monitoring both to understand the
soundscape variability and ultimately
also to understand the distribution and
abundance of known animals
we have a recently implemented a
listening network of 12 near continuous
recording stations that record down
throughout the area here
um most of them in the South part but
also some in their in the northern part
a subset of these listening stations
have real-time monitoring capability
they use a Raspberry Pi with Wi-Fi or
iridium connection
um and they have solar panels to power
them throughout the year and those are
stations detect whistles using a
relatively simple
um embedded CNN and then send those
whistles to the cloud where people can
then go in and validate the whistles and
potentially look at and classify
whistles into different uh signature
whistles afterwards
so we think Sarasota B is a real is a an
ideal test bed for both developing and
validating signature whistle-based
population monitoring methods
um we have more than 38 years now of
suction cup recordings with individual
um individually identified animals and
all of their whistles
um we're now building a database where
we are validating
um signage whistles from these suction
cup recordings before we put them into
this database that we can then train use
to train and evaluate AI identification
methods afterwards
we also use this database to understand
uh questions of communication and
cognition including how variable or
signage whistles are how they're
acquired how um often they they change
and they do change occasionally and
other kinds of aspects of how
information encoding or other questions
of of signature whistles
ultimately we're aiming to have ai
detection methods that can then be
ported into the Sarasota Bay
um acoustic listening Network and be
used for conservation and monitoring of
the resident population down in in
Sarasota but also that are generalizable
enough that they can be implemented for
other population in populations of
dolphins around the world
um
yeah
so first up
um I'll talk a little bit about their
whistle database that we've been
developing this consists right now of uh
in in terms of raw data we have more
than 38 years of suction cup recordings
of whistles from known individuals
covering more than 900 recording
sessions
295 individual dolphins in more around
171 Dolphins recorded repeatedly
throughout the years
um so this figure here shows an overview
of the signature whistles of 269
individuals that have been recorded in
Sarasota
um so just and a very brief overview of
the variability of these animals uh
signature whistles
um
so these this raw data is gradually
being integrated into our database we're
aiming to um build a database with
hundreds and hundreds of signature
whistles per individual
um both to understand the variability in
signature results but also to understand
and evaluate how well we can build
methods that generalize from smaller and
smaller subsets or of signature whistles
out into
um
other larger more variable signature
whistles
so we have right now around 61 000
whistles in their signature in the
whistle database including around 47 000
signature results
um we're gradually curating Benchmark
data sets from these this world database
where we can then use those Benchmark
database to develop and validate um AI
algorithms specifically focusing on
recognition of uh signature results
indominus dolphins
so a little bit of what we know about
signature whistle so far from from
especially the the long-term studies
down in in Florida we know
um that signature whistle Contour shape
is stable over decades so here we have
some examples of three different
individuals in their signature whistles
over recorded over more than a decade
apart
so I'm gonna see if this works
so this is the same individual recorded
across uh 10 years
um add intermittent or intervals
depending on when it was caught during
these Health assessments I'm gonna say
play the second one down here
so this just to show that the overall
structure and the time frequency
structure of these signature whistles is
highly stable over
um period over more or less the lifetime
of these animals and there are
exceptions
um we mainly see those expressions is
that the same over um from juvenile to
adult or is it from a what are they age
age differences between those 10 years
just curious
I don't actually have the age of the
animals here I can look those up but I
did not uh check on those at this point
so
most of them are caught the first time
when they're juveniles
um often caught with their dependent mom
so
um and the whistles the signature
whistles
tend to crystallize after a couple of
months already so they develop
relatively fast for for young young cops
so they it would be more or less the
same for a juvenile as as these
so there's a lot of information in these
uh Contours you see the top animal
f159 F is for freeze brand
um has a lot of frequency jumps in his
uh in in her signature whistle those
jumps seem to be at least somewhat
consistent throughout the signature
whistles and they're not super com
common for other
um signature whistles
there are other Things That Vary a lot
from rendition to a rendition you we see
a lot of overlapping uh click trains and
burst pulses those tend to not be
stereotyped within a signature whistles
um but we but now that we're putting
together the state space where we're
accurate at a point at which we we have
identified some some signature whistles
where the burst pulse component does
tend to be uh stereotyped and present
every single time
so one uh thing that does vary a lot uh
in signature whistles is their
sequential structure so here in the top
you see a signature whistle with a
single Loop going up and down and up at
the end
these Loops can be repeated a variable
number of times
for the same signature result so here
just below the first one you have a
rendition with two loops and the end up
sweep you have a rendition with three
Lubes with four Loops going all the way
up to 11 loops
and those uh that Loop Number tends to
be very flexible and probably a lot more
context dependent
in the bottom here you see an animal
with a discontinuous loop structure so
that has a space in between each Loop
rendition but that's not necessary for
Publications whistles it surely helps
seeing the repeating uh loop structure
but not all of the signature results
have uh spaces in between repeating
loops
another likely context dependent
variation are different subtle or not so
subtle modifications that tend to happen
with signature whistles that can be
deletions as you see here in figure in
in row b where each of these
um whistles show a bit of the whistle
deleted from the signage whistle it can
be different uh biphonic structure or
amplitude modulations within the
signature whistle that are not
um those tend to uh not be stereotyped
and then we have our occasional
um additions to Signature whistles that
in some cases can be quite extensive so
here you see F 296
or his typical signature whistle this is
one signature whistle where the burst
pose component tends to be very
stereotyped
and then in the just to the right of
that you see the same signature whistle
but with varying numbers or varying
degrees of additions at the very end of
uh one of the loops
and we still have a lot to uh to do to
understand this uh contextual
variability of signature whistles it's a
big field
um one thing with recently made Headway
on is to increase
um is to understand some of the changes
to signage whistles that happen in
context of cops so this I apologize for
interrupting I don't know how to raise
my hand so that you can see it no
it What proportion of signature earlier
you said that it it was just the pitch
Contour that mattered but here you have
an example signature whistle with like a
noise burst
and so I'm wondering is this one
extremely rare individual or there is
there like a population like all the
ones off the east coast of Florida use
noise bursts and the ones in the west
coast use just pitch Contours I'm just
wondering how common not just pitch
Contour is to this that's a super super
good question
um all of the playbacks that were done
to uh test whether or not animals
responded to um Pitch Contours only
we're done with
signature whistles from animals that did
not have any other
non-contour feature and so so we cannot
really say whether or not if we deleted
um for example the burst pulse component
from this individual signature whistle
whether or not that like animal would
still be recognized from conspicers
because those experiments have not been
done
um that being said non-contour features
um are rare but seen both in in but seen
in all of the populations that we've
looked for them like we've seen we see
them in Sarasota we see them in shock
Bay where uh Stephanie King and Richard
Connor works
um
but
so so it's not like there are
something that's only specific to a
single population and that's one of the
reasons why
um we we started off doing
detection classification and clustering
based on signature whistle Contours and
most of what I'll be showing in this
talk we've gone beyond the Contour and
using we use the entire spectrogram
specifically because we don't
necessarily know how important some of
these non-contour based features are to
animal recognition
okay
so one of the things we have recently
been looking into this is from a paper
um coming out in a couple of weeks and
being asked by Leila sahib where she
looked at the signature whistle
structure of females either with or
without their cough
and in the presence of the cough
signature whistles tend to be shifted
upward but only the maximum frequency of
the second choice so the main Contour
tends to be the same location
um the same sensor frequency or the same
median or Contour frequency
um
irrespective of whether or not you have
a Kafka but for all all of the females
she looked at there was either a subtle
or pronounced shift in maximum control
frequency when animals were with a cough
and she
um interpreted this as a version of
motherries as bottlenose dolphins
changing subtly changing their signature
whistle
um to accommodate
um in the presence of cough to help
either with social learning or vocal
learning as it's been suggested for in
humans or to help with um promoting
bonding of the animals
so next up I'll go through a little bit
of the efforts we've done to classify or
recognize individuals based on their
signature whistles and we've tried to
address a couple of questions here first
of all whether or not we could automate
classification or signage whistles
despite the seemingly large variability
especially in our Loop number
um second how much uh we wanted to know
how much sample size Matters especially
because no matter how much uh how many
years of data you have you're always
going to be have some individuals that
are represented with just a handful
um of signature whistles and whether or
not then secondarily we can compensate
for a low sample size of signature
whistles by simulating the natural
variation in battle and stuff and
signature whistles and third of all in
this we haven't gotten so much to yet is
the question of how we extend these
methods to entirely new populations
where we don't have an existing
signature whistle catalog so that one is
much more on our to-do list for the
future
these efforts um have been done
especially in collaboration with the
Allen Institute of AI including Piper
filters Louisa van zylan Gracie Aramis
Scott Smith Kenneth James Sam mckennock
and these people are now
um just recently started a non-profit
called Earth Sense AI that you can look
more into for following some of their
work
so the reason we
um were interested in AI based
classification of course is this is
probably preaching to the fire here cnns
and all the Deep learning architectures
are really great at finding and
extracting patterns
and so this figure here is from a public
challenge data um challenge where with
detecting right whale up calls right
whales are critically endangered uh
citations not a reliving
um on the east coast of the US
um and so this challenge here was made
to detect or evaluate different
detectors and how well they were able to
perform on a North Atlantic right whale
up poles and so here in the left side
you see a variety of detectors developed
throughout these data challenges based
on traditional feature extraction and
then in Gray
um you see deep learning based detectors
and they just bar out compete
um traditional feature-based detectors
both in precision and in recall
so our initial approach to our
bottomless dolphin classification has
been
um a very simple CNN based approach
we've developed the initial Benchmark
data set consisted of 72 different
individual bottomless Dolphins each with
200 signature whistles per individual
those signature whistles were um split
into training dates of that validation
and testing
and these are for every whistle we then
construct spectrograms and feed that
into our classifier in this case a
mobile net V2 and generate predictions
so initially
um we're getting really good performance
per
um at our top end for a lot of signature
whistles and here we show how that
performance declines as we focus only on
a subset of these signature whistles we
know we have 150 signature whistles per
individual and we gradually just ignore
a larger and larger part of that to
evaluate how well training or prediction
accuracy
um depends on sample size as we decrease
our training data set so here we have
SIMPLE training data set decreasing to
100 signature whistles per individual 50
signature whistles 25 and then
performance complete deploets ones we
have ten or five signature whistles per
individual
so then we started augmenting the
existing
um in some cases very limited so there's
training data set so we do
um we do that by introducing natural
variation to their limited uh signature
whistles and producing a number of
replicates per each signature whistle
that ultimately brings us up to a total
of 150 training whistles but from a
limited number of for example five
signature whistles per individual or 10
signature results per individual
for each individual signature whistle we
stretch it in time with plus minus 10
seconds we change the pitch up or down
by up to 10 percent
and we mix in
the we mix up the signal with ambient
noise from
from the the environment and that
ambient noise condition we wanted to get
a um a system that generalized well to
really novel conditions so what we did
was we went into the open source
um data produced by NOAA during the
sanctuary sound project
um and sampled year-round acoustic
recordings from Seven long-term field
sites around the us including still
wearing Bank in Massachusetts Grace
Reeve in Galveston Florida Keys in
Florida so Grace Reef in Georgia sorry
Florida Keys Santa Carolina Islands
Monterey Bay Olympic Coast Washington
and the Hawaiian Islands and so we take
a natural excerpts or just small
excerpts of noise from these conditions
and mix up with our known signature
whistles at a specified sickness noise
ratio of -6 to up to 12 plus 12 DB to
simulate just the natural variability in
uh signals to noise level that we can
see on a acoustic recorder
so in this way using this data
documentation pipeline we can take a
single signature whistle and we can
augment it to generate as many different
and independent
um
replicates of the that signature we're
so subtly different
um as as we want
so using this data augmentation
um workflow we get a lot better
performance especially at low at low
sample sizes so here we have the black
and red curves they show the same as
before validation accuracy and
especially important the test set
accuracy
and then the blue here is a new
um
data set that we develop by mixing up
the test step these raw suction cup
hydrophone recordings
um into uh data set or into noise from
our passive acoustic listening Network
add realistic signals for noise ratios
so again this is data noise conditions
that their network has not really been
trained for but we're hoping that it
would generalize from the sync sound or
noise conditions to pick up specifically
on the whistle signature whistle
Contours
was there a question in there
okay
so ultimately we're getting reasonably
good performance
um with this basic um CNN
we um then continue this development uh
now we're trying to uh go beyond uh cnns
to a Transformer based uh classification
uh we're using a Dyno developed by our
Facebook
Dyno Vision Transformer it's a
self-supervised vision Transformer
Network
um and what some of the benefits are
that it's capable of focusing on objects
of interest and images
um to a remarkably High degree and is
also able to categorize objects into
groups based on physical properties even
in cases where it's not been trained for
so if this is a these are images
um
embedded into a latent space using this
Dino Transformer and you see how
especially the animal species falls out
very well even though it was never
classified specifically to um
or a trained to classify any of these I
know um
yeah properties
so now we're taking this Transformer
based
um
Network
um where we're implementing we're
attaining freak we're taking
spectrograms of signature whistles as an
input to a Dyno model this Dino backbone
is pre-trained on imagenet 1K
um and we're using the dino backbone to
generate latent features or latent
latent space representation of the
spectrogram and then uh one we visualize
that lates and feature space using
tisney and we also use the latent
feature space to predict whistle
identity uh using a support Vector
machine framework
so these initial results are really
really promising uh we're still missing
some
um some progress here but initially
training the um a support vessel machine
with 40 known signature whistles per per
individual and evaluating on a remaining
160 or whistles gives us a very high F1
score of 0.95
if we extend this uh and train with a
hundred and signature 160 signature
whistles out of uh 200 we get an F1
score 0.98
and this is on a um benchline data set
of now a hundred dolphins with 200
signature whistles so we've expended
their Baseline data set a little bit
um this is all worked on by Matt Hyer
here in my lab that's out continuing
some of these efforts
one big caveat here is we still haven't
evaluated these uh class patient models
I'm sorry I'm I'm so sorry you just said
something provocative
200 signature whistles are you saying
that dolphins have more than one
signature whistle per dolphin
no no no no 200 replicates of the same
signature whistle okay each dolphin but
independent replicants
okay never mind thanks yeah
okay so one big caveat here is
performance has not been Quantified with
um signage whistles and merged with um
um acoustic noise yet it's only
evaluated on these clean suction cup
hydrophone recordings so this is
something we still need to build in
so
just to summarize
um so far we have a reasonably accurate
class patient of known signature
whistles
um
and that's um
feasible even with relatively low sample
size as long as we do re or realistic
um data augmentation with those um few
signature whistles
for each um
so far it looks like classification of
signature whistles using this latent
feature space or maybe more accurate one
of the reasons we wanted to move towards
a latent features based classification
was it's easier to allow for things like
anomaly detection classifying signature
whistles of individuals that were not in
our training data set it and potentially
we could extend it for a complete
unsupervised clustering so it's easier
for us to take something that works well
in in Sarasota and expanded out to other
populations as long as we can evaluate
how well it works in Sarasota and using
our known
um signature whistle database there
um one question we have a lot of
questions that we're still thinking
about but one of the things I'm I'm very
skeptical of is whether a latent feature
space from a Transformer model trained
just an image data is really ideal
so we're thinking of how to potentially
pre-train or
um or pre-train their Transformer model
to get a more domain optimized feature
space that can better allow for
um classifying or even clustering
signage whistles in the future
so with that thank you all for listening
um I'd like to give a shout out to
especially who's been fundamental in
collecting all of the data for the
signature whistle database
um and who's organizing or a lot of the
initial labeling committing of data
um I'd like to also acknowledge the
initial AI development team from ai2
um
and then our funding initially for from
Vulcan machine Learning Center for
impact and dolphin as well as dolphin
quests building foundation and the
Office of Naval Research thank you
foreign
sounds that they uh just use to identify
themselves or they actually have a
meaning but uh you know they also
different between each dolphin that we
use to identify them
and uh if if it's just you know a sound
that they used to identify themselves is
this something that we also observe on
in other animals for this specific to
dolphins
um one they're very most definitely
definitely used to identify themselves
and to identify con specifics
um that being said there's a lot of
variation in signature whistles that we
still do not understand some of the
contextual variation or we're starting
to get a um and an understanding of but
a lot of their modifications that we see
in signature was all during natural
social interactions we still have not
figured out what the purpose of of them
are
um we know some some
um information is encoded in the rate of
signature whistles animals that tend to
be under or like that seem to be under
more stress tends to produce signature
whistles at a higher rate
um at a lower interloop interval or
shorter interloop interval so they're
closer together
[Music]
um
but yeah there's a lot more information
on that front what was the second part
of the question
uh yeah if this is something specific to
dolphins or also other animals such as
this signature kind of sounds no that
that's a great question
um
it's definitely shown for for a
bottomless stuff and this is studied as
a signature source of studies
extensively in Balance Dolphins it's
likely that a lot of the other delfanids
produce some sort of signature whistles
we've got an increasing evidence from
other species of delfinids
that they also have at least some uh
types of signature whistles
animals that live in permanent social
groups including Orca and
um tidal whales
the question is a little bit more it I I
think there's a lot more doubt of
whether they have individually specific
signature whistles or instead have
evolved or group specific
um Contours or repertoires so
I'd say at least many of The Delfonics
will are producing certain whistles but
some of them we we're still like the
jury is still up for
thank you
hi friends great talk thank you so much
so much work
um I had a quick question of
um do you have much uh information on
how the signature whistles fall along
lineages I know a lot of Layla's work
years ago showed that the males uh new
young males calls tend to look like the
moms and I know we showed that in our
lab too females it was questionable do
you have an information over Generations
what what's going on with those the the
uh
Contours yeah Layla is actually
revisiting that question right now so I
so I cannot I like I I should not be uh
saying much more about what what she has
found but there's definitely some
evidence of um of Contours that that do
show very very significant similarities
within literatures but but she's
revisiting right now um this very
question and the other quick question
just telling uh just to follow up I know
um The Marine Mammal Research Foundation
um SAM ridgway's Group over there had
reported that they found a second
signature whistle this is related to
what you had asked before in their group
of animals which seem to be a group
called that they all shared and then the
but all the animals still had their own
signature whistle have you found
anything at all like that within amongst
these uh subgroups or groups no but I I
love all these questions
um we have some uh we have a few
incidents where we
um in during periods when we have D tags
on animals and they're roaming out or
they're in the wild and interacting with
the conspic cervix we have a couple of
incidents of
tagged males interacting with other
specifics and this is after our focal
follow has ended but where those males
and some of the non-uh specifics we
don't know the identity of of which
specifics there are associating with at
this point but produce it started
what is probably accurately called
chorusing with one type of non-signature
whistle that they were emitting all that
more or less at the same time three four
five different individuals emitting the
same
non-signaturistical Contour at the same
time
thanks so much whether or not that's a
little bit similar to what is is
found in their
um in San Diego I I don't know but I
expect it's something similar to that we
do have
um periods when Dolphins change their
signatures so these males
do occasionally switch over to a
different signature whistle that
reflects or resembles more their partner
signature whistle it's rare but it does
happen
so in those cases
those animals then have a secondary
signature whistle and we do have
examples of an adult male with a with a
bonded partner who has a new signature
result but still occasionally produces
his juvenile signatures
sorry thanks so much that's great thanks
hey friends great talk awesome huge
amount of work uh it's excellent I just
wanted you to say because I think you
said in an interesting spot as a bio
acoustician who studies animal
communication and has at least dabbled
or perhaps more than dabbled in uh to
the computer science side of machine
learning if you could talk a little bit
yeah
um if you could talk a little bit about
like where you think automation could go
like where your students spend huge
amount of time annotating or what do you
think the low-hanging fruits are for you
know people in this room who are who are
experts on the computer science side or
where you think just from your
experience the real hard nuts are going
to be in terms of you don't necessarily
understand or see a way where computer
machine learning is is going to bring us
forward on thanks I I think one of the
issues that I I look forward to seeing
some creative
um opportunities for is pausing out
some of the much more complex
interaction vocal interactions that we
see in the field with for example dtec
recordings
um where it's not just signature
whistles being exchanged it's it goes
beyond it it it's
animals moving from
um exchanging whistles initially to
starting to
um pop at each other or emit jaw claps
at each other to starting some of these
uh complex
um like coordinated cracks Theory series
to presumably coordinate motion with
their partner like I think there's a lot
to do to understand uh and Link together
um sequences of um acoustic data to
behaviors and behavioral changes
um in in animals and that's such a
complicated question
okay thanks
so I stick to the easy part and just
classify some signature whistles yeah
you and me both
do you think it's an annotation issue
like do you think it's the that creating
the data set on which the machine
learning can happen is the challenge or
do you think there's
like where do you think that challenge
is in your personal experience over
I think probably to some degree
collecting the data sets and then
annotating but with
the biological context necessary to ask
biology questions right and that's I
think the really hard part it requires
some sort of focal follows or maybe
drone follows that can start to link up
what the animals are doing acoustically
to what they're doing behaviorally
um I think that would be really really
um interesting to be able to do but man
it it's it's complex to do
yeah the question is Mark Parker
thank you for the great talk uh so I was
just wondering if you could tell us what
your experience with conducting playback
experiments with dolphins in the wild
was like
um how would you change how you do the
same experiments in the future and I
think we've uh also it said he started
to think about some of these questions
but uh it'll be great to hear from you
and see how what your take on this is
yeah that's a really good question
um
we've done in Sarasota
um and this is mainly Vincent Yannick
and and
um
that have been during most of these play
bags
um but most playbacks have been done to
animals during the health assessments
um oftentimes using animals helped by
people and then with a speaker to one
side and looking at head turns either
towards or away from the speaker as a
response variable
um we've done over the last five years
we've started to do more and more
playbacks to wild animals after the
health assessments
um both with d tags on animals and also
occasionally with drones to follow and
track behavior from from a drone
perspective
um
we've had issues with
um unexpected responses unexpected
especially aversive responses during the
initial playbacks we did to
um wild animals after Health assessments
either because they were a little
sensitized to strange sounds or because
they're
um signals noise ratios that we were
playing back was
odd for them or they there it was a
novel stimuli that came out of the blue
without for example preceding clicks or
of course specifics that they could hear
um so recently we've started
incorporating preceding click trains
into playback so that you have some
information that and econ specifics is
available or is in an area before you
start to hear a signature whistle and
and can pass that out
um
but otherwise yeah I'm not sure what to
um I I think our success so far has been
like we've had much more success looking
at and during drone
um based follows um to to observe um
playback responses and that's also
something that Stephanie King has uh has
really um had a lot of success within
Shark Bay
so
um more I'd say it's definitely easier
from extracting real response variables
from a drone perspective than from a
dtac perspective what you do get from
the acoustic Tech perspective is receive
levels and things like this that can be
important for if you're interested in
things like those response functions how
how your response varies as a function
of loudness of the signal
I I have one final question then I'll
stop asking questions
um you know I was the guy I don't know
if you saw the previous talk I was doing
generative modeling
um
I would wonder what would happen if your
drone made a new signature whistle that
you know wasn't a part of their group
um you know what could you start some
kind of an interaction with Okay click
click click brand new signature whistle
and you're always using that when the
Drone is out there so that you know it's
sort of introducing itself as a new
individual have you ever considered
trying something like that
it's like we've thought of
generative algorithms for either
producing hybrids
um between two known signature whistles
um or producing completely novel
signature whistles
um and it's something I'd love to
discuss more about
um
from a real-time perspective that's
really uh that sounds very futuristic
so I don't think we've we've been
considering anything like that
especially because the Drone doesn't
really have a hydrophone in the water
um but yeah it is interesting whether or
not we could
um come up with experiments that that
implemented real-time novel signature
whistle playbacks so it might be more
for my buoy perspective we have uh Ed
Hui we or Aaron Mooney's hat lab has a a
buoy with a speaker attached that you
can send signals to and transmit
um playbacks from so that might be
smarter than a drone for perhaps thank
you France we uh we we really appreciate
this talk and uh
um sending best to you and your growing
family and thank you so much yeah thanks
for staying up so late on your end all
right well of course I love the
of this thank you for accommodating uh
my online talk sure thank you
[Applause]
foreign